I didn't like my father
thank you it was poor and not successful
despite working harder than all my
friends fathers I didn't think he was
very smart it's not for you
I've never seen him as an inspiration we
are late for school
I asked oh sorry I have no here's your
pocket money
a bit of extra time to pay your taxes
it's from you it's from me why are we
not rich who says we are not rich being
rich it's not about how much you have
but how much you keep and somehow when
you give you'll be happier I wasn't
happy I didn't want to be poor like my
father when I grew up I knew I wanted to
be more successful than my father
call me when you need more money
are you coming back for union dinner
this year no I'm not coming home this
year yeah a new job here
maybe after New Year we'll see yeah I'm
really busy now okay bye
thank you for coming mr. Lim so good to
finally meet you in person I've always
let her sing they have been donating
money to the Community Chest
there must be a mistake I'll explain
later there's someone would like to meet
you
come with me thank you for coming mr. Li
your father stood us so much about you
your father he always makes us forget
about problems it reminds us of our
dreams and hopes but the kids here at
the old my team and he's the only one
who could bring a smile on their faces
and I remember there's this boy he was
really depressed and he didn't go to
school
basically it's given our life
your father he we do this by regularly
this fire has not grown up to be a
really useful person your father gravity
comfortably and he chose to continue
working so he can help even more people
he was selfless man it's just it it's
just that he didn't tell anyone about
his sickness Sameer
I've been trying to reach you this is
for you in recognition of your donations
but I didn't do it he said that he
didn't want you to know
is from you
it's from me
for my father's birthday I would
celebrate his life
SEF on Danny
I could almost hear him say being Reach
is not about how much you have but how
much you can give